hello everybody and welcome to another
money-making guide uh this one has very
low requirements all that you need to do
is finish the priest and paril quest
which legitimately has zero requirements
all you have to do is kill a level 30
monster so super easy uh we get probably
100 to 200k cash stack if you can and
yeah all you have to do is come to
canifis which is just east of verac or
you can use fairy rings or a couple
other ways to get here but should be on
your map so just look and all you have
to do is go from the bank you're going
to run a little bit north uh you're
going to go to this food shop and you're
going to be looking for rofus which
likes to wander around a lot so it could
be to the left of the building sometimes
to North uh usually he's in the shop and
you're just going to buy out uh the raw
sharks and all the Raw Bar meat uh once
you buy it all out you're just going to
hop worlds and I have noticed that
sometimes will disconnect you for
hopping too quickly but usually it's it
takes enough time that it shouldn't and
yes we're going to switch worlds and I
tested this out for a couple minutes
here and it looks like yeah I should get
about 400 to 500k an hour uh but we'll
do it full full hour just to show you
and uh we'll get a timer up here in just
a second okay so we'll put it out for 60
minutes I start and yeah I'll check back
when the timer's
done all right so we have about under a
minute yeah 45 seconds left and uh yeah
so I did this for an hour it really
wasn't too bad uh there was no one
really competing with me for the
ingredients there was a couple people
but uh for the most part the shop was
full which is a big benefit it's very
assistant um the Sharks will insta sell
for sure but the Raw Bar me you have an
option you can either leave it in there
for a while to get the most out of it or
you could sell them instantly for a bit
of a less of a profit but it's kind of
up to you um I did get disconnected a
few times but I I just slowed it down a
little bit and it didn't seem to really
affect my progress too much yeah see
look the shops are almost always full um
so yeah we're done the timer here so
we'll just run back to the bank and
we'll just check how much we managed to
get to 2 one
Z stop that okay so let's just check the
bank here so we got a final load and in
total we
got 1,138 bare meat and 151 raw sharks
so yeah we will just go to verac and
check how much it's worth okay so we're
in verac uh we're just going to sell up
the ingredients here uh so yeah the raw
sharks we'll just sell for minimum but
they will insta sell for sure there we
go and the baram me I think you didn't
to sell it for maybe 200 but we'll put
it in for 250 and leave it in for a
couple hours just to see what you could
expect if you're a patient H yeah so it
didn't sell any so we will check back in
an hour or
two okay so everything is sold uh we
sold all the bare meat for 250 it took
about a couple hours uh but it'll be
worth it in the end the price of bar has
been a little bit low but either way you
can see we still made 400k uh we started
with 200 now we got 603 so it's a really
easy method if you just want a couple
extra bucks um no requirements pretty
much EX for membership uh and I have
made 500k when the price of bar me was a
bit higher so it might be worth checking
what the price is at currently um but
yeah so I hope you guys enjoyed if you
want to see a couple more methods like
this just hit that subscribe button and
I will see you guys next time